fans of the famous dude perfect group
will surely be familiar with the two
twins kobe and corey cotton also known
as twin number one and twin number two
respectively it's hard to keep up with
them although they are identical twins
the two of them lead different lives
while both brothers are a part of the
crazy trick shot crew one of them is a
published author with a wife and kids
the other has lost the most battles in
duke perfect history younger brother
corey cotton can lay claim to having the
most wins but there's a lot you probably
don't know about him one of the first
things you will notice about cory when
you start to dig deeper into his life is
his real first name is not corey born
july 17 1987 corey cotton was born
william cory cotton according to the
duke perfect fandom site this is also
the case for his twin brother kobe who
was born john kobe cotton of course it
doesn't exactly help keep things simple
when two twins with similar names like
cory and kobe become friends with a guy
named cody as in cody jones fortunately
it's easy for fans to tell the three men
apart as the twins are easily
distinguishable based on physical
characteristics
and cody looks nothing like them at all
speaking of twins they tend to run in
the cotton family cory cotton is already
known as twin number two born only a
minute behind his twin brother kobe
who's known as twin number one this twin
sibling rivalry is one of the best
dynamics seen throughout the various
dude perfect media and corey seems to
better his brother in that aspect corey
has won a total of seven battles while
his older brother has only won four and
it doesn't look like the twin sibling
rivalry will stop with corey and kobe on
november 18 2018 cory and his wife amy
surplus became parents to twins and
named them crew and collins they're
probably too young for a fierce sibling
rivalry like the one between their dad
and uncle but it will likely happen one
day most of the guys in dude perfect
have some sort of role outside of making
incredible trick shots according to
fandom corey likes to help the editing
team make the final version of the video
this may not seem to be within his
particular wheelhouse corey received a
bachelor of arts in speech
communications from texas a m university
according to his linkedin profile but
when an extra hand was needed for the
editing process corey was the first to
jump in kobe also a communications major
helps with the mobile apps the dude
perfect guys have had to face some
hilarious and sometimes cruel
punishments over the years unfortunately
for corey he received probably one of
the worst punishments ever i just i have
had a bad streak and over time seven
corey had to shave his eyebrows eyebrows
don't grow back overnight and takes
about four to sixteen weeks for eyebrows
to grow back this is hands down the
longest lasting punishment making it
probably one of the worst ones fans have
ever seen cory doesn't only make trick
shot videos and suffer through
entertaining punishments for living in
2011 corey published go big make your
shot count in the connected world this
book took readers behind the scenes of
dude perfect and dove deep into the
gobig philosophy the book also goes into
their secrets of success and shares some
tips on how to take your passion to the
next level that's just one of the many
things the guys from dude perfect have
accomplished aside from the youtube
series documentary mobile apps and tours
most of the guys have admitted they
don't want to make trick shot videos
forever although they would like to keep
the brand alive they realize they will
have to focus on other things such as
family and other career ventures for
corey he has his three children and wife
to focus on and possibly more books in
the future check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite youtubers are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]